si bien hay que tomarlos con cautela
porque justamente se trata de sondeos es
un panorama alentador para este bloque
de derechas y para un posible regreso de
leche de Primer Ministro Benjamín de
tañaju que según estas encuestas se
publicadas por las dos por dos cadenas
privadas en el Canal 12 el Canal 13 y la
cadena pública can le darían entre 61 y
62 escaños lo suficientes en los
necesarios para tener una exigua mayoría
y volver a gobernar mientras que la el
bloque liderado por el actual ministro
Primer Ministro interino Jake rapid
llegaría alrededor de 54
lo más importante y la cifra que más se
ha resonado durante toda la jornada ha
sido la alta participación sobre todo
teniendo en cuenta que la seguidilla de
elecciones había generado cierta apatía
en el electorado sin embargo en la
última cifra que se ha conocido a las 8
de la noche en la participación estaba
siendo la más alta desde 1999 y aquí que
dividir en dos situaciones por un lado
la baja participación árabe que se venía
sosteniendo en la jornada lo cual redujo
las posibilidades del bloque antinieta
ñaju y también una un alza en el que se
vio entre los votantes Ultra ortodoxos
Pero igualmente habrá que esperar a que
avance el recuento para tener esto más
consolidado Federico de confirmarse el
panorama que están mostrando estos
sondeos en los resultados finales Cómo
se conformarías eventual coalición
liderada por netan Yahoo o hace el abu
yusef el secretario general del frente
popular de liberación de Palestina Ya
dijo que estos resultados o que estos
sondeos lo que muestran es que el país
está volviendo más derechista y más
extremista
eso Sin lugar a dudas porque el gran
Aliado de netañejo para este regreso al
poder sería el Alianza accionismo
religioso que es un partido de extrema
derecha que tiene líderes composiciones
muy radicales anti Árabes racistas y
homófobas este grupo que solía ser
marginal hace unos años se ha convertido
en prácticamente el que puede resultar
la llave para la conformación del
próximo gobierno el otro pie de esta
Alianza son los dos partidos Ultra
ortodoxos que como decíamos con esta
alza en la participación que aparece
haberse visto en este sector terminarían
dando el empujón en el final si se
confirman los resultados a Boca de urna
para un regreso de netan Yahoo al poder